are you tired of losing chess games and
feeling like you're not getting any
better
the fact is most chess players do not
improve their chess because they don't
know how to change the way they think
about the game
welcome to chess mentor the most
intelligent interactive chess training
system in the world chess mentor is
designed to help all levels of chess
players from beginner to expert improve
their chess faster than any other chess
teaching method using chess mentor is
like getting personalized private chess
lessons from some of the top chess
coaches and grandmasters in the world
with chess mentor you'll stop those bad
habits and stupid mistakes that are
causing you to lose boost your rating
and tournament performance to maximum
potential learn how grandmasters view
the chess board so you can correct your
way of thinking the secret to chess
mentors powerful teaching engine is that
you get in-depth analysis of every
single possible move on the chess board
most chess programs give you a puzzle
and then simply say wrong when you make
a mistake leaving you to wonder why it
was a bad move but with chess mentor
when you make the wrong move you hear
from a top chess coach exactly why the
move you picked was wrong so that you
can actually change your mental
understanding of the game it's like
having a grandmaster sitting next to you
giving you feedback on every single move
the second piece of magic behind Ches
mentor is that you never have to guess
Gissing doesn't help you learn anything
with Ches mentor you have an amazing
assortment of tools and hints to help
you arrive at the correct answer on your
own stimulating your thought process and
helping you relearn the game chess
mentor will open your mind to a totally
new way of thinking about chess chess
mentor has dozens of courses designed to
target all areas of the chess game from
openings to tactics to middle game
strategy to end games each course is
created by world renowned chess
instructors and grandmasters like Jeremy
sillman Nigel Davies mark Lasky and John
Griffey just to name a few
let's go through a lesson together so
you can see exactly how chess mentor
works chess meant to are places you in a
variety of positions with varying
challenges it gives you a synopsis of
the game we want to make sure that you
read all of this information because
it's definitely helpful and set you up
for what's ahead
you also get hints that come with every
lesson use those hints and avoid the
temptation to guess and the tools are
indispensable you can see the goal for
this lesson black wants to play for
positional gain you can see the material
that's already been taken the difficulty
for this lesson
the total number of steps involved and
we can go ahead and get a subtle hint it
says our target is c2 but the knight on
d4 is making that a little bit difficult
what I think we'd like to do is make an
exchange with the knight so let's go
ahead and get in position for that and
it seems that is the correct move let's
go ahead and continue white sees the
threat that's coming up and tries to
support that square well we'll do those
take a look at the key pieces for this
move
the key squares we can even have chess
mentor tell us the correct piece to move
and even the correct square we can also
take a look at a strong hint whites
Knight is the glue holding his position
together thus black wants to trade his
knight for whites defensive steed
so not only telling us what the correct
move is but why and now we've got our
last move for the lesson we can look at
the move importance three out of ten we
can get a direct hint take the knight on
b5 and if we have to if we're absolutely
stumped we can even have chess mentor
show us the answer as you can see the
tools that come with chess mentor
provide you with an amazing array of
resources that'll help you focus on the
correct parts of the chessboard and
chess mentors responsive learning engine
makes it feel like you're learning from
a real chess coach what's more your
progress is tracked and lessons are
customized according to your needs
you get a full report that summarizes
your strengths and weaknesses letting
you visualize how much you're improving
over time think about it for just a
minute a good chess book will cost you
$25 and it only gives you non
interactive material usually focused on
one topic and a book doesn't know how to
adapt if you're having difficulty
mastering a topic then when you're ready
for another topic you have to buy
another $25 book private lessons from a
grandmaster can cost $100 an hour
and you have to worry about scheduling
and availability with chess mentor you
learn from some of the world's greatest
grandmasters any time you want some of
the best chess players in the world have
helped contribute to chess mentor and
for only pennies a day you can get
unlimited access
isn't it time to improve your chess with
the number one chess program in the
world sign up today you'll get ten
lessons absolutely free so you can see
for yourself how easy it is to start
making real progress on the chess board